july 2017
and carrie lam is sworn in as hong
kong's fourth chief executive
she'd been the territory's deputy leader
so this had been expected
what was unforeseen though were the
tumultuous events that followed
months of protests in 2019 led to the
imposition of a wide-ranging national
security law
it stifled dissent but provoked an
exodus by those who no longer saw a
future here an exodus that has grown
since the lamb administration
further tightened already strict
measures to combat covet 19.
more than a hundred thousand people have
left this year alone in my view the way
the 2019 protests were handled
were
evidence of incompetence an incompetent
leader and political incompetence
in other parts of the world politics
matters but here we choose leaders with
no political skills and this is the
communist party's deliberate decision to
do this lamb says she informed mainland
china's leaders about her wish not to
seek a second term more than a year ago
yet waited until now to make it official
i will not be taking part in the
election for the sixth hong kong chief
executive
i will complete my five-year term as
chief executive on the 30th of june this
year
and i will also call an end to my 42
years of public service
candidates who want her job have another
12 days to submit nominations it pays
more than 670 thousand dollars a year
and comes with a palatial colonial era
residence
her deputy john lee is reportedly about
to enter the race carrie lam declined to
comment on her performance during the
past five years but in recent weeks
she's been widely criticized over her
handling of the fifth outbreak of covert
19 and the fact this city now has one of
the world's highest death rates from the
virus
lamb once complained about the strain of
serving two masters the hong kong people
and china's leaders
it's a balancing act her successor will
likely have to continue
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong